If the content hash of 1096 and 123b are exactly the same, then
we can modify the PPN to MPN mapping in VM2 for the page 2868,
which used to point to 1096, we can now make it, point to
123b because they both are exactly the same content. And once we have done that,
then we increment the reference count to this hash
table entry to 2, indicating that there are 2 different virtual
machines that map to the same machine page, 123b.
And, we're also going to remember that these two mappings. Between
PPN 2868 to 123b, 43f8 to 123b are
copy on write entries, indicating that they can share
this page, so long as these 2 virtual machines are reading it. But if any one of
them tries to write it, at that point For the integrity of the system,
you have to make a copy of this page and change
the mappings for those PPNs to go to different
MPNs, that's the reason that we want to do this copy on write. And now, we can
free-up page number 1096. So there is one
more page frame that's available for the house,
in terms of allocation. because all of these
things that I mentioned just now, are fairly
labor-intensive operations. So you don't want to do this
when there is active usage of the system.
So, scanning the pages, that is. Going through
all of a virtual machine's pages to see
if pages that are contained in a virtual
machine may already be present in the machine
memory reflecting the contents of some of the
virtual machine. That kind of scanning you want to
do it as a background activity of the
server, when it is lightly loaded. Looking for such
matches and mapping the virtual machines to
share the same machine page and freeing up
machine memory for allocation by the hypervisor.
And the important thing that you have to
notice is that, as opposed to the
earlier mechanism that I mentioned where I said
that with the coninements of the guest operating
system, the hypervisor can get into the page
table data structures inside the guest operating
systems. No such thing here. It is completely
done oblivious to the guest operating systems and
therefore, there is no change that needs to
be made to the guest operating systems. In
order to do the sharing in an oblivious
way. And this technique is applicable to both
fully virtualized, as well as the paravirtualized environments.
Because basically, all that we are saying is
that, let's go through the memory contents of
a virtual machine, and see if. The memory
contents of the virtual machine, any particular page
frames can be shared with other virtual machines,
and if so, let's do that. And free
up some memory. That's the idea, can be
applied to both fully virtualized and para virtualized settings.